>> Jesse: TRUMP'S TWITTER
ACCOUNT SHOULD BE SUSPENDED.
>> HIS TWITTER ACCOUNT SHOULD BE
SUSPENDED.
I THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF NO
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT HE IS
IRRESPONSIBLE WITH HIS WORDS IN
A WAY THAT COULD RESULT IN HARM
TO OTHER PEOPLE AND THE
PRIVILEGE OF USING THOSE WORDS
IN THAT WAY SHOULD PROBABLY BE
TAKEN FROM HIM.
>> Greg: FURTHER PROOF THAT
KAMALA HARRIS WOULD MAKE A BAD
PRESIDENT.
WHEN FACED WITH SOMETHING, THEN
IT.
AND REALLY SHE'S NOT COULD HELP
HERSELF I.D. TWEETING TRUMPET
AND THAT IF ANYTHING, THAT MIGHT
HELP HIM.
HE IS LAUNCHED HIS OWN METHOD
MESSAGE BOARD AND WITHOUT
TRUMP'S SITE, THEY HAVE TO START
COVERING REAL NEWS WITH STEAKS
FOR WORK.
WE ALL RESENT MS. HARRIS FOR
TAKING AWAY ONE OF THE MOST
STRIKING PHENOMENON SIMPLY
LITTLE HISTORY, LEADER OR
COMMUNITY IT'S DIRECTLY TO THE
PEOPLE CUTTING OUT THE MIDDLEMAN
KNOWN AS US, THE MEDIA, I'M
NOXIOUS OR NOT, IT'S MOST
TRANSPARENT ADVANCEMENT IN
POLITICS.
THE OPPOSITE OF THE
CHOREOGRAPHED INTERVIEW BETWEEN
POLITICS AND THE PEOPLE.
NO WONDER SHE HATES IT.
SHE'S TERRIBLE AT BEING
AUTHENTIC PAID SHE'S AS REAL AS
SPANDEX.
AS CREDIBLE AS THE GAS STATION
CHILI DOG.
I'VE NEVER SEEN A CANDIDATE'S
OWN COMFORTABLE IN HER OWN
PANSEARED.
>> Jesse: THE ONLY PERSON WHO
LAUGHS MORE THERE OWN JOKES AS
THE JOKER.
>> IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
DRINK OUT OF THE PAPER STRAW --
IF YOU DON'T GULP IT DOWN
IMMEDIATELY, IT STARTS TO BEND.
AND THEN THE LITTLE THING
CATCHES IT AND THEN YOU KNOW BUT
WE'VE GOT TO KIND OF FIGURED
THAT ONE OUT A LITTLE BIT MORE.
SPEAK OKAY.
WHICH TREE?
WHICH WE?
>> ABOUT SAYING IT IS THE
MODERN-DAY LYNCHING.
>> SORRY.
OKAY SO --
>> Jesse: IS A WEIRD REFLEX
AMONG OUR THESE DAYS NOT TO
ENGAGE IN DIALOGUE BUT TO PRESS
IT.
INSTEAD OF DEBATING EACH OTHER,
DUBBED THESE INTERESTING VOICES
INSTEAD OF LISTENING TO THE
OTHER SIDE.
CALL THEM DESPICABLE OR
DEPLORABLE INSTEAD OF ACCEPTING
AN ELECTION AND CALLING IT
LEGITIMATE PAID WHAT OF ALL OF
THESE TACTICS HAVE IN COMMON?
THEY KNOW THEY ARE A LOSER.
I HAD HIGH HOPES FOR
KAMALA HARRIS IN THE BEGINNING.
>> Dana: SHE WAS THE FIRST TO
ANNOUNCE THE RUBIO MODEL.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Dana: EVEN PRESIDENT TRUMP,
I THINK AT THE TIME TWEETED THAT
SHE HAD A BIG CROWD AND HE WAS
IMPRESSED WITH HER.
I THINK RIGHT NOW SHE'S DOING
EVERYTHING SHE CAN TO PUNCH
THROUGH IN THIS NEWS CYCLE
BECAUSE WHEN YOU START TALKING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT, THERE IS NO
ROOM FOR ANYTHING ELSE BUT SHE
HAS TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO DO
THAT.
THE OTHER THING THAT SHE TRY TO
DO TODAY WAS TO MAKE SOME NEW IS
BASICALLY SAYING SHE'S GOT SOME
STAFF CHANGES ON HER CAMPAIGN
WHICH IS AN ACKNOWLEDGMENT THAT
THINGS ARE NOT GOING THAT WELL
THAT SHE HAS NOT ANNOUNCED HER
CAMPAIGN FINANCE NUMBERS FOR
THIS LAST QUARTER.
I BET THEY ARE NOT --
BEFORE SHE HAS.
I THINK SHE'S RAISED OVER TEN OR
$11 MILLION.
LOOK, SHE'S A PHENOMENAL WOMAN.
A WONDERFUL LAWYER.
IF YOU EVER NEED A LAWYER I
WOULD HIRE HER.
BUT WHAT SHE WAS SAYING IS THAT
WORDS MATTER AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT WORDS OF THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES MATTER.
I THINK WE NEED HIM TO TIMEOUT
SOMETIMES ESPECIALLY OVER THE
WEEKEND WHEN I'M WATCHING
FOOTBALL AND THE PRESIDENT IS
TWEETING 80 TIMES AND IT'S ALL
LIKE SAYING NOTHING.
SHE --
GREG, I KNOW BETTER.
SHE WAS MAKING THE POINT THAT
HIS WORDS MATTER ESPECIALLY WHEN
THE PRESIDENT SOMETIMES RETWEETS
PEOPLE WHO ARE SAYING THINGS
THAT MAY NOT --
YOU KNOW.
>> Dana: IT WAS $11.6 MILLION
FOR HER CAMPAIGN.
SHE DID ANNOUNCE IT.
>> Jesse: IT'S ON THE RECORD
AND WE WILL HAVE A MEETING AFTER
THE SHOW TO DISCUSS IT.
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
TO DON'S POINT, JEDEDIAH, IT'S
HARD UP FOR NOT TO LECTURE US ON
WORDS WHEN DAVE SAID A LOT
OF HORRIBLE THINGS ABOUT
CONSERVATIVES GOING BACK TO
REAGAN, GOING BACK HOWEVER LONG
AND SO NOW WE'VE GOT A GUY THE
KIND OF FIGHTS BACK AND I'LL
SUDDENLY --
>> Jedediah: EVEN ON TWITTER.
HE HAD SO MANY PEOPLE ON THE
LEFT THAT WANTED TO DESTROY THE
KIDS AND THAT SET OUT TO DESTROY
BRETT KAVANAUGH THAT DECIDED HE
WAS GUILTY, JUST TRY TO RUIN HIS
WHOLE CAREER, SO EVEN IF YOU
DON'T LIKE HIS FEED, SOMETIMES
I'M LIKE MILLENNIA, TAKE THAT
AWAY.
I GO TO THE RANGE OF EMOTION BU
BUT --
>> Dana: IT'S NOT THE LEFT
ATTACKING THE RIGHT, --
>> Greg: BUT NOBODY CARED
UNTIL TRON.
>> Jedediah: THE PROBLEM IS
YOU WOULD HAVE TO BAN SOME NEW
PEOPLE THAT YOU WOULD HAVE TO
BAND THE WHOLE PLATFORM.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU RETREAT
STUFF THAT INVOLVES CIVIL WAR, I
MEAN, ADAM KINZINGER DID
ANNOUNCE THAT.
GREG IS GOING TO TAKE ME BACK TO
GRAMMAR SCHOOL.
HE IS NEVER BEEN THERE.
>> Greg: NOW I'M INTERESTED.
>> Dana: IT'S JUST THAT I'M
SITTING SO CLOSE TO JESSE THAT I
CAN SHARE IT.
>> Greg: IN ANCIENT ROME A LOT
OF THE RULERS WOULD BAN THE
LOOKS OF PEOPLE WHO THREATEN
THEIR POWER AND THEN THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH WOULD ISSUE
THEIR HANDS ON OF THE COPERNICUS
NOVELS AND THINGS LIKE THAT
BECAUSE THAT THREATENS THEIR
IDEOLOGY AND AS YOU REMEMBER IN
1440 WHEN THE PRESS WAS INVENTE
INVENTED, --
YES.
OTHER GUTENBERG'S THROUGHOUT
EUROPE BUT WHAT THIS SAYS IS
WHEN THE ELITES KNOW THAT THEIR
POWER IS THREATENED BY NEW IDEAS
AND NEW PEOPLE THERE INSTINCT IS
TO DESTROY PIT IS NOT TO DESTROY
OR TO DEBATE, IT IS TO DESTROY.
THAT'S WHAT KAMALA HARRIS AND
ALL THE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN DOING
ON THE LEFT RECENTLY FOR A LOOK
AT RUDY GIULIANI BID THEY TRY TO
KEEP HIM OFF THE AIR.
LOOK WHAT THEY DID WITH TROUT'S
TWITTER ACCOUNT, LOOK WHAT THEY
DID WITH BEN SHAKIRA WHO IS
ABOUT 5'3", LEAST THREATENING
GUY IN THE WORLD, HE CAN'T SPEAK
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE HE'S LOOKED SO
THREATENING.
THIS JUST SHOWS HOW WEAK THE
LEFT IS AND THEY CAN'T PERSUADE
WITH IDEAS AND HOW THEY ARE
TRYING TO TAKE AWAY YOUR VOTE.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
IF THEY CAN'T BEAT YOU ON THE
TURF, THEY JUST REMOVE THE TURF.
>> Jesse: THERE'S AN
SAYING, POLITICS IS A CONTACT
SPORT AND PEOPLE NEED TO GET
TOUGHER.
WHY ARE WE ALL PROTECTING ALL OF
OUR SUPPORTERS FROM THESE HARSH
MEAN WORDS FROM THIS MONSTER IN
THE CLOSET?
>> Donna: THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND WORDS MATTER,
THAT'S WIDE.